we want to make earth as habitable
and livable and since we're accelerating
this this change we want to
live in balance with with spaceship
earth
in today's episode we're taking another
look at our planet
from the outside in simply we're trying
to design a healthy relationship between
people
technology and our earth systems for
sustainability of humanity and all the
living things on the planet
i'm your host sarah hansen today on
chalk radio we're talking with apollo
program professor of astronautics
dava newman professor newman is an
expert in aerospace engineering
and she's used that knowledge to forge
new perspectives on climate change
you can check out professor newman's
course 16423j
aerospace biomedical and life support
engineering on ocw
as well as for climate-focused resources
in short professor newman has worked on
some very cool things
including better spacesuits for
astronauts once designed for much longer
journeys into space in the future
in research i specialize in astronaut
performance and biomedical engineering
as well i spend a lot of time thinking
about uh
humanity becoming interplanetary
literally when we'll have
humans going back to the moon and mars
and design of
suits and life support systems and
experiments to keep our astronauts
healthy and well during
long duration flight and about
50 percent of my research is now in um
climate might kind of frame that as
earth systems
as an engineer myself looking at complex
systems well there's there's no
more complex system i submit than earth
systems and that includes
oceans to land to air all the way to
space
because of her background as an
aerospace engineer professor newman
takes a unique approach to climate
change
many of her teachings draw on this
approach and the lessons from her time
at nasa
i served as nasa deputy administrator so
that's the number two during the obama
administration
from 2015 to 2017
and most people think of nasa and think
of human space flight that's my
research specialty and background but
really it's all the aeronautics
breakthrough research as well the
huge amount of uh earth science research
related to climate
we have 100 science missions flying at
any one time exploring
the solar system and beyond exoplanets
nasa's always been
my agency but to be able to be a leader
at nasa and also
join the civil servants that was really
quite quite an honor
and it's definitely changed my research
and we're talking about climate i came
back to mit as the apollo professor
and said you know what's the most
important thing i can be working on
every day
and my answer changed after my nasa
experience now the answer is
climate or systems secondarily getting
people to mars
part of her work with earth systems or
systems that span our globe and connect
us as a planet
is helping people understand this more
global perspective
professor newman has some powerful
insights about organizing people
around this kind of big picture thinking
her time at nasa
coordinating international efforts
informs her approach to climate action
and research
as an aerospace engineer we have a
pretty specific
i think special perspective it's called
the overview perspective so
you know anyone who is an aerospace
engineer we're always looking at data
from satellites and from space
first the human experience in space when
the astronaut is in low earth orbit
looking down on earth
spaceship earth as i call it and so
we're all on this spaceship earth
together
guess what we're all the crew we're
actually all astronauts because we're
we're orbiting around our sun and uh
that's how i think we need to
think about climate and accelerating
positive change it's a it's a global
issue it's an earth-wide
issue and i think the overview effect
you can really look at earth down on
earth get into the data but it's equally
as important as the human spirit
and thinking about collaboration it's
not a nation
state issue at all we want to make earth
as habitable
and livable and since we're accelerating
this this change we want to
live in balance with spaceship earth
recently professor newman co-founded the
non-profit organization
called earth dna it's a global platform
for climate advocacy
and action earth dna works to inform and
facilitate climate action
by first sharing knowledge about our
planet in a way that's available
and accessible to everyone this spirit
of teaching openly and collaboratively
is one that professor newman and her
earth dna co-founder
guillermo trotti care about deeply we
call earth dna our life project
it's open source and we would really
envision a platform
for climate advocacy and action it
starts with
knowledge and education i'm i've been an
educator my whole life so it starts with
the educational piece
we're using a lot of artificial
intelligence i call it curating the data
you know petabytes of data literally
data from our satellites so we have so
much data
that gets overwhelming even for me as an
engineer and scientist
but for sure for someone who's you know
busy working and they just want to know
a little bit more about climate
we have to i i call you curate that data
use our artificial intelligence use
these
wonderful visualizations so people say
ah i get it i get temperature change i
get
ocean change the hard piece the second
piece is changing human behavior
so the point about earth dna simply
trying to design a healthy relationship
between people
technology and our earth systems for
sustainability of humanity and all the
living things on the planet
can't waste a second we can't waste a
day it's so urgent in the next decade
to do i think whatever all of we can
through all of us
to really move the bar to really
accelerate positive change for the earth
part of what makes earth dna unique and
uniquely accessible
is its focus on meeting people where
they are
literally you can talk about temperature
global temperature things like that but
i think we care about our own
our own zip code we care about our
family and friends so what i care about
is what's happening in my backyard here
i have family in
montana and california on the west coast
and we have relatives in argentina so
you know i have those five zip codes in
and what i care about is oh what's
happening here
maybe what can i do in those places so
the point being that we need to
have global information we need to zoom
down to maybe regional
and then we need to care about local and
and so maybe you maybe you love
turtles maybe you love things out in the
ocean
we're trying to be a network that can
connect these things and give you
news that might be relevant to you
what's happening
tomorrow saturday you know maybe i can
go join some some friends and we could
do a little bit of a beach cleanup
something like that you know just
something simple that i enjoy doing
but trying to connect people that are
like-minded
[Music]
professor newman and her colleagues have
developed another powerful strategy for
helping people learn and engage around
climate issues
they've separated earth into four
different subsystems
there's no silver bullet for climate
it's really all these complex
systems working together so the oceans
first and foremost because the oceans
are our largest
subsystem and then the land where you
know most people live
on land and then from the land
air and then space i count space again
back to my roots i'm
i'm biased i'm an aerospace engineer but
that's really where so much of the
information is coming from near space so
our satellites our eyes on earth
the information that we can see from
spaces when we get that
that global that holistic view so that's
why
i put those four subsystems there we we
need to work in all of them
but i think i find it helpful to talk
about those four
earth subsystems because someone might
have affinity oh for me it's the oceans
oh no for me it's the land
and that's kind of the fundamental part
of the mission
it's to make the world work for a
hundred percent of humanity
an important part of climate science is
making models that help us predict
what's likely to happen in the future
this posed a particularly complex
challenge for professor newman and the
earth dna team
how do you convey complex climate models
that draw on tons of data points and
variables
to those of us who don't have a
background in climate science
we have so much data from our satellites
for earth systems or maybe just even
take ocean data if you will
take a look at well what's the sea level
temperature what's the sea level
rise you know kind of coverage of the
whole earth and then again we want to
zoom down
into something regional let's say the
north atlantic we can look from
say new england where we are at mit all
the way then across
the atlantic taking all that data going
deep
into reducing it and we can generate
satellite images from the future
i could put that in your hand perhaps if
we
immerse people in these uh these future
visions or
boom you know kind of teleport yourself
to anywhere you want in the world
and you know so it's the storytelling
and the storyline
i think hopefully also will engage
people and get people involved and
hopefully people can ask questions and
people to think about okay what can i do
and we could serve up a whole bunch of
different opportunities different
actions that they could take even though
a lot of this is open source it's really
hard to access you
takes a lot of time can take an hour of
digging let's say on a
nasa website to find what you might be
looking for well wouldn't that be neat
if you could just
speak to me and give me a couple key
words and say what you'd want and then
boom i'd serve it up now we don't have
that capability yet but
that's what we're working on we want to
make it that easy
[Music]
for this episode we also had the chance
to ask professor newman some of your
questions that you submitted to us
one of the questions was this does the
earth have global climate
cycles and is climate change possibly
just part of a normal cycle
earth does have cycles uh earth is 4.5
billion years old
and so we've had weather and climate
through
those billions and billions of years so
there are cycles
but no we are not in a normal cycle by
any stretch of the imagination
this is an incredibly accelerated
response since
the industrial revolution we actually
can
calculate the percentage of climate that
is
a human cause human induced there's some
tools out there some simulations you can
imagine well what if i use this much
energy
what if we emit this much carbon dioxide
oh what if we
cut down by 50 and what we're striving
for is where's that balance where's that
balance
for people having healthy wonderful
successful you know getting economically
successful
lives but just always trying to keep
that in mind
our effects on climate and how we can
change things and how we can do much
better
another one of your questions was this
how is climate change transforming
people's lives and societies
at a broad level climate change impacts
every single one of us and it's going to
get more acute
and it's going to get more intense
globally we definitely see it
immigration people moving and people
don't ever want to leave their house
right you want to stay
with your family and friends but if
you're forced to especially by
natural disaster but especially by war
but i think that we
really need to show people the the
connections the connections between
climate and health so again that's
really important today
let's link we have the climate data we
have health data but let's
link them because they're very very
linked we can talk about asthma we can
talk about
people's changing health issues and we
can look at that and say
you know what there's a climate link
there and that's i think an important
discussion to have
another question you submitted was what
are one or two of the biggest challenges
that governments and concerned citizens
of spaceship earth
should try to solve in order to prevent
or mitigate climate change
i love that question and my answer is
really just a discussion with that
person
what do you want to do because i think
it's important that people go with their
passion
there's so much to do there's something
that everyone can do so i like to
kind of ask it back not to not to not
answer the question
but just to know a little bit more about
that person and say what do what do you
like what's what's really your passion
and then if i know that again it could
be something for the oceans maybe
it's something for animals or land or
something like that maybe it's pollution
and plastic
so good we love a challenge well that's
what's the
plastic of the future what's the
synthetic biological was they know
the was the biological new
material not plastic but new material in
the future that acts
like plastic probably couldn't live
without plastic but let's reinvent it
let's reinvent it
so that is completely sustainable and
that's there's research going on
on that right now but hopefully that's
just an example for
someone for that question um kind of
seeing what they like to do and what
they'd like to get involved in
and our last question from listeners how
long do we have before it's too late to
do something about climate change
i'd like to rephrase that a little bit
and say
now is the time to act no more excuses
no more
pushing this off onto the other
generation
everyone everyone can do something today
and these are little things these really
are not
inconvenient things these are things
that i think everyone actually would
feel
good about so the time to act is now
[Music]
thanks for joining us for another
episode of chalk radio
we hope you're feeling inspired and
motivated to start taking some steps to
mitigate climate change
based on your own passions and interests
don't forget to check out professor
newman's courses and her earth dna
resources on our website
you can also visit earthdna.org
signing off from spaceship earth i'm
sarah hansen from mit
opencourseware hey before we go
did you know that ocw has a birthday
coming up we're turning 20 in april
for two decades we've worked to share
mit course materials with the world
your support helps us to do so freely
and openly
and helps make resources like this
podcast possible
if you're able to give please consider
donating to ocw
at ocw.mit.edu
so we can stay open for the next 20
years thank you
mom passed the car